[Music]
be proud ethan ross remember to stand
tall be proud of who you are and don't
let them take away your courage you are
strong and very brave keep being you kid
remember speaking up doesn't always make
life easier but easier never change
anything
[Music]
Ethan's a young man of that reached out
to me my name is sue
I wrote a letter to him sterling because
I had racial abuse at my school when a
ladies at the club that reads our fan
mail that I think this is a really
touching subject that I feel you should
have a look at in and I did people he
says shout which shape you sent me for
most states in school you know writing
back to Ethan and of course with what
effort has gone on with me I just
thought it will be you know really nice
to give him some word of encouragement
and also help obviously in school and it
was quite it was quite half me to deal
where I really wanted him to you know
know that I've seen the messaging I'm
thinking of him and the situation I he's
he's been in someone that relates to him
in that way and not only just me that
support him
[Music]
growing up in London I've never quite
experienced any racism at all and then
going up north to Liverpool those were
the first time I'd come face to face
with it but I didn't feel that would
mentally affects me
you know if it was my passion I'm not
gonna make some one or some other people
ruin my dream police here in London have
said they're investigating claims of
racial abuse towards Manchester City's
Raheem Sterling during Saturday's
Premier League match at Chelsea there
was racist abuse directed at England
stars from the stands in Montenegro as
capital Podgorica which has led to
Manchester City star Raheem Sterling to
call on football authorities to take a
proper stance hey Chelsea
and just seeing the the pure frustration
anger on people's faces and if you say I
got there was you know definitely a
point where looking at the fans that
they made me realise that this is a lot
more than just football the best way I
tried to deal with this not to get angry
is always try to you know let the foot
will do the talking and then afterwards
try to address it now I forget or be
good as if you know people in charge go
to players who have been racially abused
and you know arts for advice and help us
to try and make a better change never
mind I got my Jordans on it has to be
the one has to be the one we don't we
over with you it's going one oh what a
sick get it
you know it's nice to be able to give
him some words of encouragement and you
know after what he's faced so it's it
makes makes me smile makes me happy my
friends in school is a very
inspirational letter other people who
are having this can reflect on this you
knows young kids are you know look up to
us and how much we can do to help and
you know support them and show them that
we are there for them as well we know we
can't reach out to everyone but at the
same time you know these little things
who mean a lot to people no it's a real
lovely gesture and hopefully can you
know in case anyone at the school Anna
roses see anything is a lovely message
in the walls inside that letter I
started talking about to eat your eye
out my big scene is if I don't get back
to my communities where I'm from and
helping out there with the next
generation is a little bit over when I
play football really so I always speak
out when I when I feel I need to be
heard and not just sit there and make
things fly by couldn't the best thing
you could do is to speak up and and let
people know your opinions because
everyone's opinions mouth
[Music]
you